en Touraine en tout cas on se prépare à
l'arrivée de l'Irlande des artisans
locaux se mettent même à créer des
produits à thème pour la Coupe du monde
de rugby on en parle tout de suite avec
notre invité
bonjour Baptiste Cochereau bonjour vous
êtes chocolatier à Notre-Dame-d'Oé et
fan de rugby c'est ça actuellement vous
êtes en train de créer dans le
laboratoire de votre chocolaterie qui
s'appelle fève une tablette de chocolat
éphémère qui sera vendue à l'occasion de
la présence de l'équipe d'Irlande à
Tours pourquoi les spéciales cette
tablette elle est spéciale parce que
c'est un événement spécial déjà de base
d'accueillir la première nation mondiale
de rugby c'était une chance pour la
ville de Tours et on s'est dit que
c'était le meilleur moyen pour nous de
faire une tablette éphémère de mettre en
avant un produit de l'Irlande donc on a
voulu travailler l'Irish Coffee dans une
tablette et donc voilà on s'est dit
pourquoi pas essayer de relever ce
challenge à mettre un iris au fil à
l'intérieur d'une tablette et donc
l'idée c'est de pouvoir la manger de
manger un carré de chocolat avec de la
bière alors soit en effet manger le
chocolat tout seul soit accompagner d'un
whisky irlandais ou avec une bière on a
nos confrères de la petite maze se
développer une bière en faveur de
l'Irlande aussi donc ça se mariera très
bien avec je vois que vous nous avez
amené une tablette c'est ça fait parler
des premières premières tentatives que
vous avez faites ouais on a calé le
visuel là ça y est maintenant il est il
est définitif
on a décidé le visuel alors pour plein
de raisons et puis là on est en train de
travailler du coup sur la recette
peaufiner vraiment les goûts pour que on
sente bien tous les codes de la riche
coffee qui sont la crème le café et le
whisky
vous faites beaucoup d'essai d'ailleurs
pour en arriver là ouais sur le visuel
déjà ça a été plein d'ajustements entre
ce qu'on a le droit de faire et ce qu'on
a pas le droit de faire parce qu'il y a
des codes aussi qui sont soumis à des
droits et puis sur les essais là par
exemple on a fait déjà deux essais qui
sont qui s'approchent de ce qu'on veut
mais qui manque encore un petit peu de
de whisky notamment donc c'est c'est des
ajustements qu'il faut faire donc il y a
bien une dizaine d'essais en tout
vous dans votre chocolaterie vous
travaillez en Bintou bar c'est à dire
que vous fabriquez vous-même votre
chocolat à partir des fèves brutes
est-ce que ce procédé cette manière de
travailler ça vous permet d'être plus
inventif dans les recettes et je pense
notamment à celle-ci oui en fait on peut
travailler des produits différents des
la genèse de la recette des qu'on va
travailler nos fèves dès qu'on va
concher le chocolat donc c'est une étape
où on travaille le chocolat pendant
plusieurs heures et donc on peut y
intégrer des ingrédients à ce moment là
et donc avoir des chocolats complètement
originaux et très intéressant c'est ce
que vous avez fait pour cette tablette
là c'est ce qu'on a essayé de faire
ouais tout à fait on travaille pas mal
avec la maison gramme aussi qui sont des
torréfacteurs de café sur tout centre et
donc on a essayé de travailler alors on
a fait deux essais un ou on vient mettre
du grain de café dans notre guimauve
directement donc la guimau qui a apporté
le côté crémeux du de l'ailh coffee et
puis un autre où c'est un chocolat où on
a directement intégré notre grain de
café dans notre recette de chocolat et
donc c'est ce chocolat qui va venir
enrober notre notre tablette
faire des recettes à thème comme ça vous
en faites assez souvent est-ce que c'est
une manière de vous démarquer de la
concurrence oui parce que on propose
essentiellement nous des produits de
tablette on va pas proposer de ballotin
comme des chocolats traditionnels on met
en avant ce qu'on se travaille du Bintou
bar et de transformation de la fève on
reste sur des produits bruts comme la
tablette donc ça nous impose d'être
assez inventif et d'avoir des recettes
qui se renouvellent pour pas avoir des
choses qui sont tout le temps monotones
et qui sont toujours pareil pour nos
clients et vous avez ouvert il y a
seulement 8 mois oui en plus dans un
contexte d'inflation est-ce que vous
parvenez à dégager une marge suffisante
sans répercuter ça sur les prix de vente
pour l'instant on y arrive mais en effet
c'est impacté sur notre marge un jour ou
l'autre on sait qu'on va devoir faire
une augmentation
après on est encore jeune on a ouvert il
y a 8 mois donc c'est compliqué de
trouver le bon moment pour le faire
entre se sentir assez légitime pour
pouvoir le faire et puis ne pas non plus
mettre en péril
la viande de notre société parce que
voilà comme tout le monde on a des
augmentations partout donc c'est à
prendre en compte quand même merci
Mathis Cochereau